okay finally 20 points now firstly let's
just think about the same question okay
why clearance when I said that tell you
points they sort of usually overlap
which stationary points but they don't
know it right so number one I can find a
station for that it's not a turning
point okay so I can't say she's turning
points exist when the dude of zero
because that's not always true but just
looked at a counter right so what you'd
have to say if your question was find
the twenty points is turning points may
exist okay it's a big difference
they may just win okay from there it's
what it proceeds very similar to the
previous thing right we're gonna find
out where the coordinates of the point
are eventually you'll get zero zero okay
but at this point all you verified is
that it's a stationary point okay so if
for instance let's actually do why it
was executed right because it turns out
the stationary point is at the same
place so I've solved for the derivative
being equal to zero
and I've landed here okay I've shown a
stationary point now I need to find out
is it at any point or not okay now there
are two methods to verify whether it is
or not I'm just gonna go to show you the
first one the second one comes with the
second derivative we will get someone
okay really quickly draw yourself up a
table okay it's got two rows the first
one is X and the second one is dy on DX
and then what you want is a table of
values for yourself
so you start at or sorry not start up in
the middle you've got the value the new
found of stationary point okay so at
zero what's the derivative it's zero
then you need to pick a point on either
side okay they have to be real points
like say minus 1 and 1 and also these
points that you choose they can't be too
far away I'll explain why tomorrow ok
this will do for now
then you need to actually find out what
the values of the derivative are on
either side ok now in this case why
cruise excuse
dy/dx is 3x sweat okay
so therefore when X is minus 1 you pop
it in the derivative of this site will
be 3 and the dude on this side will also
be 3 ok it's not enough to just say
positive and positive ok even though
that's actually the fact that I'm after
ok we want to see that you've actually
got some values and don't fudge it ok
that's one of the things markers we need
for therefore what kind of shape do we
have well whatever it is increasing
horizontal increasing in a the turning
point okay so therefore I would say no
turning points exist for y equals an
execute alternatively if it was
something that did have turning points
you know why it was x squared you say it
goes negative then 0 then positive so
you've got different kind of shape
students say there is a turning point
you might say it's a bit of a turning
point at 0 0 relatives